you direct something like Parenthood now
you did you probably acted like I read
something like 100 episodes you acted in
right yeah something like that yeah and
when you're directing Craig T Nelson
right and these other actors was it was
a little bit since you're working with
them so much that you felt like oh I had
to prove myself because I felt like that
I had to show them that I know what I'm
doing you're in good hands trust me did
you feel like there was a sort of yeah I
think a little bit yeah no
um uh you know and also I knew that some
of them wanted to direct and we're you
know looking down that so I think there
was there was a a light competition
maybe in were you the first that got to
direct I was the first and then Dax no
no Peter cross had directed the year
before us so and I think you know people
are worried once somebody one of the
actors directs and all of a sudden all
the other actors want to direct and it's
not really their passion but they were
like well that's an opportunity I should
take right and uh I had you know I if it
weren't for taking me home I I wouldn't
have gotten the job you know but I had
proven that hey this guy can tell a
story and he's passionate about it so
um but yeah it was it was interesting it
was challenging and uh you know to add
to that um on the second day of shooting
um we were like hey uh somebody said hey
uh Ron Howard's showing up today and Ron
Howard had never he was an exec on the
show it was you know yeah derived from
his his movie and he had been on the on
the set yet and uh everybody was like oh
my gosh what's wrong I was coming to
roll you know like we set up this whole
and we had a big family scene with all
the actors in it and uh everybody I
remember somebody coming up to me and
saying uh well are you are you nervous
and I said well not I mean what's he
gonna do
Rana like Ron Howard's we've been making
money for him for a couple of years he's
going to show up on set and be like
that's a bad choice no he's gonna be
like wow this is great I'm glad you guys
are I love this show and I'm I'm glad
you guys are carrying on and carry on so
and that's what he did yeah that's what
he did he was great he was great was he
like oh so you're the director here
you're in you're the actor yeah yeah
that's great yeah what are you doing
here did he ask you what you were doing
and like well we had yeah we had a
family scene and it's you know it's a
big messy Family scene so I think it was
fun for him to see you know we shot that
show so fast it was three cameras and
the everybody was Mike and so everybody
could overlap and it has just that that
energy which is is fun to be a part of
was anyone difficult like you don't have
to say their name but was any of them
just it was like they were it was a
challenge to direct them they were like
they yes that sure was sure but you know
you it's it's it's more difficult
because I knew them so there were
certain times where people would try to
um get out of work or say hey can I I
don't know why I'm in this scene can I
just not be in the scene or you know and
you'd have to work around their
personalities that if if I worn a cast
member they would just be like well okay
I'll just show up and do my work but
right since they know me they're like I
don't know if I I don't really I don't
think I'm really needed in this scene
you know it's like yeah uh yeah it was
just you had to kind of suck it up when
you wanted to say dude just fine this is
your first time directing the show just
[ __ ] do you just do your job yeah
yeah oh and also it'd be like you know
you're just I'm gonna have you done by
11 A.M that's you know so if you can
just give me a morning you can have
coffee come to set and by the time
you're done with your coffee you get to
go home so just give me that was it I'm
guessing it was a male character it was
not it wasn't no it was not wrong no no
I won't say anything else no no I won't
I won't put you on the spot here
foreign